Apple's new standard MacBook has been
out for just about a week now and we've
been really enjoying it here in the
office with all of our testing but if
you're looking to buy one of these new
M2 MacBook airs there are a few problems
you need to be aware of before you buy
now we're not trying to hate on this
MacBook at all because it truly is a
great laptop and the design is amazing
we're just pointing out the downside so
you're aware of them and we actually
have some recommendations on how to
avoid some of these problems as well now
before we get into the top 10 problems
after one week I've got to give a shout
out to the sponsor of this video grid
Studio who take what would have been
E-Waste like over 10 000 discarded cell
phones and turn it into Arts like this
framed disassembled iPhone 4S which is
the perfect gift for Apple lovers so
check out all of their awesome art
pieces using the link below now getting
into the first problem about the M2
MacBook Air the speakers now Apple hyped
up the speakers like crazy saying that
it has a new four speaker system which
sounds like it should be so much better
than the previous two speaker system but
in reality the speakers aren't actually
that much better first of all there's no
more speaker grilles like we used to
have the sound simply bounces off of the
display and towards the user through
some of the vents inside of the actual
hinge and unfortunately that leads to a
smaller sound stage compared to what we
had before where it sounds like the
volume is wrapping around you you no
longer get that with a new M2 MacBook
Air and on top of that the high
frequencies are cut down a little bit
and muted and we did expect a big
Improvement in the base because of the
two extra woofers that are inside of the
M2 air but not really it just barely
more bass compared to the M1 air so with
that said do not make your decision
based on the speaker upgrade alone and
here's a clip so you can hear it for
yourself
bring me back
[Music]
oh wait I almost forgot to mention our
huge giveaway of one of our four M2
MacBook Air models that we ordered and
to join all you have to do is subscribe
to this Channel and comment one time on
each one of our launch week MacBook Air
videos including this one which will
give you more entries to win before we
announce the winner at random right here
on YouTube on July 25th and even better
we'll ship it to you no matter where you
are in the world for free including the
shipping charges and import taxes now
getting into the second problem we of
course have the thermal throttling
issues and it's not only when doing
extreme workloads it's when doing fairly
common stuff as well like exporting 50
photos in Lightroom and what we're
seeing is that the M2 MacBook Air is
heating up much faster than the M1 model
and that's because the new Air doesn't
even have a proper heatsink according to
iFixit with their new territory down it
simply uses this thin metal shielding
which doesn't really do much at all for
cooling and that's really disappointing
because the previous M1 MacBook Air came
with an actual heatsink but this new
model that uses more power with the M2
Chip doesn't an apple could have
actually used this leftover empty space
on the side of the logic board as you
can see in this area from our teardown
to put in an actual heatsink and then
connect that to the M2 Chip using some
sort of heat pipe if they moved some of
the things around on the logic board but
they didn't they have no proper heatsink
but thankfully there is a solution and
that is our thermal pad mod which we did
for only 15 bucks so all you got to do
is buy one of these sheets cut it up and
place it over the logic board like we
showed you guys in our thermal
throttling fix video and just doing this
alone made the M2 MacBook Air finish the
photo export faster than the M2 MacBook
Pro which is fan powered it is a massive
difference and the only drawback is at
the bottom of the MacBook Air is going
to be getting hot during extended
workloads but the benefit is that you
get 15 minutes of full performance
without reaching massive throttling
instead of just five minutes without the
thermal pads and you get the new M2
MacBook Air redesign without having to
go for that old M2 MacBook Pro Design
just to get that fan to avoid this easy
throttling and now getting into problem
number three this also has to do a
little bit with thermal throttling
because the M2 MacBook Air at the base
price comes with an 8 core GPU but if
you really want to you could upgrade to
the 10 core version for a hundred
dollars more and it seems like you
should be getting a lot more GPU
performance however according to a video
from Greg's gadgets there was actually
some cases where the 10 chords you model
performed worse than the a core which
makes no sense at all but what ends up
happening is that the 10 core heats up
faster and thermal throttles so much
that it actually down clocks the GPU
leading to slightly worse performance
than the 8 core model which should not
happen especially if you're paying a
hundred dollars more and it shows that
this thermal system is pretty bad but
luckily you can use that thermal pad mod
to get a little bit longer full
performance without throttling and now
getting into problem number four we have
this new midnight finish which I
absolutely love it almost looks like a
matte black when it's dark and when it's
bright it looks like a dark navy blue
and I just love this color however it
does have some issues because underneath
this finish we have a regular silver
metal color so what ends up happening is
if you scratch [ __ ] it's gonna be
incredibly noticeable and not only that
we noticed some little silver lines or
scratches near the Thunderbolt Port area
after only using it a couple of times so
I can imagine after a year or two this
thing could look all scratched up
especially near the port area and not
only that but this thing is a
fingerprint magnet like crazy you just
use it a couple times fingerprints
everywhere you're gonna have to clean it
all the time so that could be annoying
and that could be a problem to some of
you guys so definitely choose a
different color if you hate fingerprints
and those scratches moving on to problem
number five another issue with the M2
MacBook Air is that once again it still
only supports One external monitor now
that is very disappointing because all
of us were expecting Apple to upgrade
this and allow up to two monitors but no
still only one so there are a lot of
disappointed people out there especially
typically people who like to use
multiple monitor setups and not only
that but we still have the same
Bluetooth 5.0 and Wi-Fi 6 specs which is
disappointing there's so many other
laptops and machines and products out
there that have moved up to Bluetooth
5.2 and I personally was expecting us to
get the new specs but no it's all the
same now for problem number six we have
the microphones which we thought would
be getting better especially with this
full redesign on this M2 MacBook Air but
no we compared them to the M1 MacBook
Air and it actually seems like the M1
previous model sounds better in terms of
the microphone quality which we did not
expect and this kind of sounds even more
quiet and a little bit muted so that's
disappointing in terms of the
microphones now that's definitely not
going to be a Make It or Break It
decision for you guys but keep that in
mind if you do a lot of Zoom calls or
whatever else now for problem number
seven we have the new keyboard and
unfortunately this one has a little bit
less travel than the previous M1 model
it seems like because this thing got
thinner they did have to reduce the key
travel and some people might care a lot
maybe not but that is one thing that is
good to know and on top of that the
trackpad also seems different as well it
doesn't seem as clicky as it was before
I don't know if that's because it got
thinner or they changed something but I
definitely prefer the clickiness and
feel of the trackpad and keyboard on the
previous M1 model now of course this is
not going to be a huge deal but once
again it's something to keep in mind and
now getting to some of the really big
problems we have problem number eight
which is the SSD speeds on the base 256
gig model just like the M2 MacBook Pro
we have the same issue where we only
have a single nand chip instead of using
up both of those spots like apple did in
the past with the M1 MacBook Air and pro
and this is important because both of
those spots have channels going to the
SSD controller and when you take out one
of those channels by not putting a chip
there it essentially slows down the SSD
speeds and while it seems like
performance is not going to get impacted
that much we did a real world file
transfer and the 512 gig SSD model
finished over six times faster than the
256 and that is just so disappointing
not only that but those SSD channels
matter a lot for a virtual swap memory
performance so when you use up all of
your RAM it starts to rely on the SSD to
act as virtual RAM and because the speed
is slower it ends up slowing down the
entire machine when you're doing some
multitasking and not even extreme
multitasking just like five Safari tabs
while doing a productivity task can slow
down the performance drastically across
a a bunch of different tests so I
believe Apple really messed up with this
SSD situation and our recommendation is
to avoid the base SSD as much as
possible just go for that 512 gig and up
and then problem number nine is actually
connected to that because this new Mt
MacBook Air starts at twelve hundred
dollars which is two hundred dollars
more than the previous M1 MacBook Air
but you have this SSD issue where Apple
took away one of the nand chips so
you're paying 200 more for half of the
nand chips which definitely sucks as a
consumer with this base model and to
properly fix this issue you've got to
upgrade it to the 512 gig SSD to revive
the actual virtual memory swap
performance that you should be getting
or that the M2 Chip actually deserves
and that's going to cost you an
additional two hundred dollars so as
essentially you have a 400 difference
for the same virtual memory swap
performance going from the thousand
dollar M1 MacBook Air to the 1400 M2
MacBook Air with a 512 gig SSD so that's
a little bit disappointing and that's a
big difference in cost for the same
virtual memory swap performance and for
file transfers as well and not only that
but you're paying 200 extra compared to
the M1 and you're no longer getting a
proper heatsink you're just getting that
thin shielding which really doesn't do
much at all so the cost difference is
really a problem on this M2 MacBook Air
and now finally for problem number 10
Apple showed off the new Max safe 3
feature with fast charging that'll get
you from zero percent to fifty percent
in just 30 minutes which sounds amazing
and apple did a great job marketing it
however if you go out and you buy the
base model you go to your Apple Store
Your Best Buy which usually just stocks
the base model you're not gonna get fast
charging support yes if you want fast
charging you have to upgrade to the 67
watt power adapter which costs an
additional twenty dollars to get or you
have to upgrade to a higher end model to
get that included which sucks because
the base model only gets the 30 watt
adapter which does not feature fast
charging so definitely keep that in mind
if you're excited about that feature and
there you guys go those were the top 10
problems with the M2 MacBook Air that
you need to be aware of before you make
your purchase don't forget to click
subscribe to enter the giveaway as well
as commenting down below be sure to
check out one of those two videos right
there and if you're interested in one of
those grid Studio frames as a gift I
have links below to that as well thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
foreign